- Maligayang pagbabalik sa Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Ako si John Watrous at ako ang technical director
para sa IBM Quantum Education.
Ito ang ikatlong aralin ng serye. Sa unang dalawang aralin, pinag-usapan natin ang mga pangunahing kaalaman
tungkol sa quantum information.
Una para sa mga solong sistema nang mag-isa at pagkatapos para sa maraming sistema.
Tinalakay rin natin ang mga standard
basis measurement at unitary operation sa parehong
solong at maramihang sistema.
Sa araling ito, ipapakilala natin
ang quantum circuit model, na nagbibigay sa atin ng isang karaniwang paraan upang ilarawan ang mga quantum computation,
at maaari rin nating gamitin ang mga quantum circuit upang ilarawan ang mga quantum protocol at iba pang uri ng pakikipag-ugnayan na kinabibilangan ng maraming quantum device.
Bukod sa mga quantum circuit, tatalakayin din natin ang ilang
mahahalagang konsepto sa matematika na konektado sa quantum information,
at gagamitin natin ang mga ito upang mapansin
ang ilang pangunahing limitasyon sa quantum information at kung ano ang magagawa natin sa mga quantum circuit.
Iyon ay magiging magandang paghahanda para sa
aralin kasunod nito kung saan makikita natin ang ilang
napakahalagang halimbawa at matatapos doon ang
unang yunit ng serye
tungkol sa mga pangunahing kaalaman ng quantum information.
Narito ang isang pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin. Magsisimula tayo sa quantum circuit model at makikita natin kung paano ito gumagana.
Pagkatapos ay pag-uusapan natin ang
napakahalagang konsepto ng inner product, pati na rin ang orthonormality at projection,
na konektado sa mga inner product. Hindi natin tinatalakay ang mga bagay na ito
sa unang dalawang aralin, dahil hindi talaga natin
ito kailangan noon, pero ngayon kailangan na natin.
Ang mga inner product ay nagbibigay sa atin
ng isang mathematical tool na hindi talaga natin maaaring gawin nang wala.
Hindi talaga tayo makakarating sa pag-unawa sa quantum information at
computation nang wala ang mga inner product.
At sa ikatlong bahagi ng aralin, titingnan natin ang ilang
mahahalagang limitasyon ng quantum information.
Sa huli, ang gusto nating gawin ay tuklasin ang mga kawili-wiling
bagay na magagawa natin sa quantum information, ngunit upang magawa ito nang epektibo,
kailangan nating maging mulat sa ilang
bagay na hindi natin magagawa.
Sa partikular, tatalakayin natin
ang konsepto ng global phase at kung bakit hindi mahalaga ang mga global phase.
Makikita natin ang isang pahayag ng
no-cloning theorem, na nagsasabi sa atin na ang mga quantum state ay hindi maaaring kopyahin sa pangkalahatan, at makikita natin na ang dalawang quantum state
ay hindi maaaring ganap na
mailayo mula sa isa't isa maliban kung sila ay orthogonal, na isang pangunahing
limitasyon na dapat malaman.
Ang unang paksa para sa aralin
ay ang quantum circuit model, na isang modelo ng computation
na nagbibigay sa atin ng isang paraan
upang ilarawan ang mga quantum computation.
Ang quantum circuit model ay
batay sa mas pangkalahatang konsepto sa computer science ng isang circuit, at maaari kang magdefine ng maraming
iba't ibang modelo ng computation
batay sa pangkalahatang konseptong ito.
Ang pangunahing ideya ay ang isang
circuit ay binubuo ng mga wire na nagdadala ng impormasyon, at mga gate, na kumakatawan sa mga operasyon
na inilalapat sa
impormasyong dinadala ng mga wire.
Ang salitang circuit ay talagang
medyo kakaibang pangalan para gamitin para sa ganitong uri ng modelo
dahil ang salitang circuit
ay karaniwang tumutukoy sa isang
pabilog na landas ng isang uri.
Ngunit kapag pinag-uusapan natin ang mga circuit
bilang mga modelo ng computation, karaniwang pinag-uusapan natin
ang mga acyclic circuit
kung saan hindi pinapayagan ang mga pabilog na landas.
Upang maging mas tumpak, para sa
layunin ng seryeng ito, hihilingin natin na
ang impormasyon ay laging dumadaloy mula kaliwa patungo sa kanan sa anumang circuit.
Kaya kung gusto mo,
maaari mong isipin ang mga circuit bilang paglalarawan ng mga pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga operasyon kung saan ang oras ay pumupunta mula kaliwa patungo sa kanan.
Narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang Boolean circuit kung saan ang mga wire ay nagdadala ng mga binary
na halaga, alinman ay zero o isa,
at ang mga gate ay kumakatawan
sa mga Boolean logic na operasyon.
Ang mga wire ay kinakatawan ng mga linya, at dito mayroon tayong dalawang input
bit na may label na X at Y,
at kung gusto nating malaman
kung ano ang ginagawa ng circuit sa isang partikular na pagpili ng mga input, ipinapalaganap natin ang mga halaga sa
mga wire mula kaliwa patungo sa kanan,
depende sa mga aksyon
na ginagawa ng mga gate sa mga halagang
dinadala ng mga wire.
Halimbawa, maaari tayong
tingnan kung ano ang nangyayari kapag sinimulan natin ang nangungunang input wire na nakatakda sa halagang isa at ang ibabang input wire
nakatakda sa halagang zero.
Ang dalawang input wire na ito ay
pumupunta sa dalawang tuldok dito, na kumakatawan sa mga fan-out na operasyon, na nangangahulugang ang halaga ay kinokopya
upang ito ay maaaring dalhin
pasulong sa maraming wire.
Kaya kung gagawin natin ito, ang dalawang
wire na ito ay kukuha ng halagang isa, na kapareho ng halagang ito, at ang dalawang wire na ito ay kukuha ng halagang zero,
na kapareho ng halagang ito.
Dito mayroon tayong NOT gate na
ipinahiwatig ng simbolo para sa logical negation, kaya ang
halagang lumalabas ay zero,
na siyang logical negation ng isa. At gayundin, ang halagang
lumalabas sa gate na ito ay isa na siyang
logical negation ng zero.
Ang dalawang gate na ito ay AND gate,
ang gate na ito ay isang OR gate, at kung magpapatuloy tayo
at ipapalaganap ang mga halaga
sa pamamagitan ng circuit, na sinusuri nang wasto
ang mga gate, makikita natin na ang panghuling halaga
sa wire na ito ay isa.
Kaya ang buong circuit ay naglalarawan
ng isang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga operasyon na pinagsama ayon sa iminumungkahi ng pigura, at nakakakuha tayo ng isang function
mula sa dalawang bit patungo sa isang bit
sa partikular na kasong ito. Ngunit sa pangkalahatan, maaaring magkaroon ng anumang bilang
ng mga input at output bit.
Ang partikular na circuit na ito ay nagkakalkula ng exclusive OR ng dalawang input bit, kaya ang output ay isa
kung at kung lamang
isa sa dalawang input bit ay nakatakda sa isa at ang isa ay nakatakda sa zero, ngunit hindi talaga iyan
mahalaga, halimbawa lang ito.
Ito ay isang pangunahing katotohanan tungkol sa mga Boolean circuit na ang anumang function mula sa anumang bilang ng mga bit patungo sa anumang bilang ng mga bit ay maaaring makalkula
ng ilang Boolean circuit, kahit minsan ay kailangan mo ng
napakalakins circuit upang makalkula ang function
na interesado ka.
Mayroon ding iba pang mga estilo na
ginagamit upang ilarawan ang mga circuit.
Halimbawa, ang pigura na ito
ay kumakatawan sa eksaktong parehong circuit na mayroon tayo noon, gamit ang isang estilo na marahil ay mas tipikal
sa electrical engineering, kung saan mayroong mga kombensyon para sa mga hugis na kumakatawan sa iba't ibang gate.
Hindi natin gagamitin
ang partikular na estilo na ito, ngunit magpapakilala tayo ng
ilang sarili naming simbolo para sa iba't ibang quantum gate, tulad ng Hadamard gate,
Controlled NOT gate,
Toffoli gate, at iba pa.
Bilang isang panig na paalala, dito maaari nating makita ang pinagmulan
ng terminong circuit.
Sa konteksto ng electrical engineering, napaka-natural na
isipin ang kuryente na umiikot sa isang circuit.
Ngunit sa seryeng ito hindi tayo
nag-uusap tungkol sa kuryente na gumagalaw sa mga circuit, nag-uusap tayo tungkol sa impormasyon
na gumagalaw sa mga circuit.
At muli para sa atin, lagi silang magiging acyclic, kung saan ang impormasyon
ay gumagalaw mula kaliwa patungo sa kanan.
Narito ang ibang halimbawa ng
ibang uri ng circuit na tinatawag na arithmetic circuit.
Sa pagkakataong ito ang mga wire ay nag-iimbak ng mga numero at ang mga gate ay kumakatawan
sa mga arithmetic na operasyon tulad ng karagdagan at multiplikasyon.
Dito maaari kang makakita ng isang halimbawa
ng isang arithmetic circuit.
Hindi mahalaga para sa layunin
ng araling ito kung ano ang ginagawa nito, halimbawa lang ito na
nilayon upang ipahayag ang ideya na may iba't ibang
mga konsepto ng circuit.
Maaari rin nating isipin ang
mga circuit na kinabibilangan ng randomness, halimbawa, kung saan ang mga gate ay kumakatawan
sa mga probabilistik na operasyon, at kung gusto mo,
malamang na maaari kang umupo nang buong araw na nangangarap ng mga bagong modelo ng computation batay sa konsepto ng mga circuit.
Sa quantum circuit model,
ang mga wire ay kumakatawan sa mga Qubit, at ang mga gate ay kumakatawan sa parehong unitary na operasyon at mga pagsukat.
Narito ang isang napakasimpleng halimbawa
ng isang quantum circuit.
Mayroon lamang isang Qubit sa circuit na ito, na kinakatawan
ng pahalang na linya, at ang mga gate, na
ipinahiwatig ng mga parisukat,
ay kumakatawan sa mga unitary na operasyon na ginagawa sa Qubit na ito.
Kaya walang mga pagsukat
sa partikular na halimbawang ito.
Kung gusto nating bigyan ng
pangalan ang Qubit tulad ng X, maaari nating ipahiwatig ito sa diagram sa pamamagitan ng paglalagay ng X dito
sa kanan, opsyonal iyon.
Tulad ng mayroon tayo para sa Boolean circuit mula ilang sandali ang nakakaraan, maaari nating isipin ang circuit na ito
bilang kumakatawan sa isang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga operasyon kung saan ang oras
ay pumupunta mula kaliwa patungo sa kanan.
Kaya magsisimula tayo sa X,
ilalapat natin ang unang gate, na isang Hadamard gate
na sinusundan ng isang S gate,
pagkatapos ay isa pang Hadamard
gate, at sa wakas ay isang T gate.
Nakita natin ang mga operasyong ito
sa pagtatapos ng aralin isa, at dito maaari mong makita
ang kanilang mga paglalarawan sa matrix.
Kaya kapag ginawa natin ang mga
apat na operasyong ito nang sunud-sunod, na nangangahulugang una ang H, pagkatapos ay
S, pagkatapos ay H muli, at pagkatapos ay T,
ang pinagsanib na operasyon ay ibinibigay
ng produktong ito dito, na isinasaalang-alang na ang order
ay mahalagang nababaligtad
tulad ng pinag-usapan natin sa aralin isa. Kung gagawin natin ang matrix multiplication, makukuha natin ang matrix na ito dito,
kaya ang aksyon ng
circuit sa Qubit X ay inilarawan ng unitary matrix na ito.
Minsan ay gusto nating tahasang ipahiwatig sa isang quantum circuit diagram
kung anong input ang inilalagay natin, at magagawa natin iyon tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Sa kasong ito, naglalagay tayo ng
Ket 0 sa circuit.
Karaniwan iyon. Madalas na itinuturing natin ang Ket 0 bilang
nasimulaang estado ng isang Qubit, ngunit hindi iyon kinakailangan.
Maaari rin tayong isaalang-alang ang
pag-aaplay ng circuit sa ibang estado.
Kung pipiliin natin, maaari rin nating
ipahiwatig ang output state na nakukuha natin tulad nito.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa kung saan
sa pagkakataong ito mayroon tayong dalawang Qubit na pinangalanang X at Y tulad ng
makikita sa diagram.
Dito mayroon tayong Hadamard gate, na inilalapat sa Qubit Y, na sinusundan ng gate na ipinahiwatig ng
simbolong ito dito,
na isang Controlled NOT gate. Pinag-usapan natin ang
Controlled NOT na operasyon sa nakaraang aralin,
at dito sa diagram na ito maaari
nating makita na ang control Qubit ay Y, na ipinahiwatig ng
maliit na puno na bilog,
at ang target Qubit ay X, na ipinahiwatig ng malaking bilog na may parang plus sign sa loob nito.
Mukhang katulad ng
simbolo para sa exclusive OR kaya makatuwirang ito.
Maiisip mo na anumang
klasikal na estado na nakaimbak sa Y ay XOR'd sa Qubit X.
At para lamang sa kalinawan, narito ang diagram na
nagpapakita ng aksyon ng gate na ito sa mga standard basis state,
kung saan ipinapalagay natin na ang A
at B ay mga binary na halaga.
Para sa ibang mga estado, ang aksyon ay tinutukoy
ng linearity gaya ng lagi.
Ngayon, bago tayo sumulong, magiging kapaki-pakinabang na
tahasang sabihin ang isang kombensyon na susundin natin tungkol sa kung paano ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga Qubit
sa mga quantum circuit diagram tulad nito.
At ang kombensyon ay ang
ibaba pataaas na pagkakasunod-sunod sa isang quantum circuit diagram ay katumbas ng kaliwa patungo sa kanang pagkakasunod-sunod
gaya ng sa isang tuple o tensor product.
Iyon ay isang kombensyon na
susundin natin sa serye at ito rin ang kombensyon
na ginagamit sa Qiskit.
Kaya para sa partikular na circuit na ito, iniisip natin ito bilang
kumikilos sa isang pares ng Qubit X, Y,
X ay una dahil nasa ibaba ito, at Y ay huli o pangalawa sa kasong ito, dahil nasa itaas ito.
Ang paraan na maisip mo ito
nang biswal, kung makakatulong ito, ay isipin ang pag-ikot ng
circuit na ito nang pakanan upang ang mga input ay nasa itaas
at ang mga output ay nasa ibaba, at ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng
mga Qubit ay magiging tama.
Minsan ang pagkakasunod-sunod na ito ay nakakabigo sa mga tao, kaya tiyaking
panatilihin mo ang kombensyong ito sa isip.
Kaya kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa aksyon na inilalarawan ng circuit na ito, ang mayroon tayo nang una ay isang
Hadamard gate na inilapat sa Y
at pagkatapos ay isang Controlled NOT
gate sa dalawang Qubit na may Y bilang control
at X bilang target.
Kung gusto nating isulat ang isang unitary matrix na naglalarawan ng pinagsanib na
aksyon ng dalawang gate na ito, magagawa natin iyon.
Una, isasaalang-alang natin ang Hadamard gate sa Y.
Inilalapat natin ang Hadamard gate sa Y at walang ginagawa sa X, na katumbas ng
pagsasagawa ng isang identity na operasyon sa X.
At kaya ang aksyon ng Hadamard gate sa parehong Qubit nang magkasama ay
ibinibigay ng tensor product ng identity matrix at
ng matrix na kumakatawan
sa Hadamard na operasyon sa Y.
Ganito ang hitsura nito, na isinasaalang-alang ang ating
kombensyon na ang X ay una at ang Y ay pangalawa, kaya ito ay
ang identity tensored with H.
Pagkatapos ay ilalapat natin ang
Controlled NOT na operasyon, na may matrix
representation na ito, at muli, iyon ay naaayon sa ating kombensyon.
Ang pangalawang Qubit Y ay ang control at ang unang Qubit X ay ang target.
Huwag kang matakot na i-pause ang video at i-verify na makatuwirang ito at titigil na ako sa pagpapaalala sa iyo tungkol doon.
Maaari mong i-pause ang mga video na ito, bumalik at panoorin ang mga bahagi
nang maraming beses hanggang gusto mo, ayusin ang playback speed kung pipiliin mo, gamitin ang mga ito sa anumang
paraang pinakamainam para sa iyo.
Anyway, kapag pinagsama natin ang
dalawang operasyon, ang pinagsanib na aksyon ay inilarawan
ng produktong ito dito,
at ang dalawang matrix na ito ay
pinarami sa pagkakasunod-sunod na ito dahil ang Hadamard ay ginagawa nang una at ang Controlled NOT
ay ginagawa nang pangalawa,
at muli, ito ay naaayon
sa kung ano ang pinag-usapan natin sa aralin isa kung saan ang pagkakasunod-sunod
ay mahalagang nababaligtad.
Kung gagawin natin ang matrix multiplication, makukuha natin ang matrix na ito dito.
At maaari na nating basahin mula sa matrix na ito kung ano ang ginagawa ng circuit sa
mga standard basis state.
Kung tatakbo tayo ng circuit sa input 0, 0, ibig sabihin Ket 0 para sa unang Qubit, Ket 0 para sa pangalawang Qubit,
ang resulta ay ang Phi+ Bell state, na maaari nating makita mula sa
unang hanay ng matrix.
Kung ilagay natin ang 0, 1, makukuha natin ang Phi- state, ang isa zero ay nagbibigay sa atin ng Si+ state,
at ang 1, 1 ay nagbibigay sa atin hindi ng Psi-, kundi -1 X Psi-.
Ang minus sign ay hindi talaga
mahalaga dito. Kung hindi mo ito gusto dito, maaari kang magsagawa ng swap
na operasyon sa dalawang Qubit
upang mapawi ito at hindi mo
masisira ang nangyari sa unang tatlong standard basis state.
Ngunit hindi talaga ito mahalaga
para sa layunin ng halimbawang ito.
Kaya sa buod, ang circuit ay may aksyong ito dito sa mga standard basis state.
Kapag nag-iisip ka tungkol sa
kung ano ang ginagawa ng isang partikular na circuit, hindi mo kailangang dumaan sa
pag-convert sa mga matrix at i-multiply ang mga ito nang magkasama,
maaari mo ring subaybayan ang
aksyon na mayroon ang circuit sa mga partikular na estado, at sa maraming kaso ito ang
magiging ginustong opsyon.
Sa halimbawang ito, halimbawa, maaari nating makita kung ano ang ginagawa ng circuit
sa estado 0, 0 sa pamamagitan ng pagsusuri sa aksyon ng mga gate.
Ang panimulang estado, na
pinangalanan nating Pi zero dito, upang maiwasan ang isang pangalan
na magiging nakakalito sa Bell state ay 0, 0.
Inilalapat natin ang Hadamard gate at ang estado na nakukuha natin ay 0+ na maaari nating palawakin tulad nito,
at pagkatapos ay ang Controlled NOT na operasyon ay nagdadala ng estado na ito sa Phi+ state, na maaari nating makita sa pamamagitan ng pag-iisip
tungkol sa aksyon na mayroon ang Controlled NOT sa
mga standard basis state,
At maaari mong gawin ang parehong bagay
para sa iba pang tatlong standard basis state o anumang
iba pang estado.
Maaari rin tayong magsama ng mga klasikal na bit sa mga quantum circuit diagram.
Sila ay ipinahiwatig ng
dobleng linya tulad ng makikita sa diagram na ito.
Ibig sabihin, ang A at B ay mga klasikal na bit at ang X at Y ay mga Qubit.
Mayroon tayong parehong dalawang unitary gate tulad ng sa nakaraang halimbawa, at ang mga simbolong ito dito ay kumakatawan sa mga standard basis measurement
Sa partikular pagkatapos na ang dalawang
unitary na operasyon ay ginagawa, isang standard basis measurement
ang ginagawa sa Y
at ang resulta ay naisulat nang muli
sa klasikal na bit, B, at gayundin ang X ay sinusukat at ang resulta ay isinusulat sa bit A.
Dito maaari mong makita na ang mga Qubit X at Y ay nagpapatuloy pagkatapos silang masukat.
Karaniwan naman
na hindi nating masyadong pinapahalagahan ang mga Qubit
pagkatapos silang masukat.
Minsan ang tanging pinapahalagahan natin ay
ang resulta ng pagsukat. At sa ganitong kaso, maaari nating gamitin ang shorthand
na estilo na nakikita mo dito
kung saan ang mga pagsukat ay may mga Qubit na pumapasok at mga klasikal na bit na lumalabas.
Ang pag-unawa dito ay na
kapag nasukat na ang mga Qubit, sila ay itatapon o binabalewala at ang klasikal na resulta ng pagsukat
ay dadalhin pasulong.
Ngayon habang nagpapatuloy ang serye, makikita natin ang maraming
halimbawa ng mga quantum circuit at sila ay karaniwang
mas kumplikado kaysa sa napaka-simpleng
mga halimbawa na nakita natin.
Gaya ng nabanggit ko kanina, iba't ibang simbolo ang
ginagamit para sa iba't ibang gate.
Ang mga single-qubit gate ay karaniwang
isinusulat lamang bilang mga parisukat na may titik na nagpapahiwatig
kung anong operasyon ito.
Minsan ang iba't ibang
gate na ito ay may color code upang mangahulugan ng iba't ibang bagay, ngunit
binabalewala natin iyon sa ngayon.
Nakita na natin ang
Controlled NOT gate.
Ang mga swap gate ay itinatanda
tulad ng nakikita mo dito, At ang mga Toffoli gate at Fredkin gate
ay itinatanda tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Alalahanin na ang isang Toffoli gate ay isang controlled Controlled NOT gate at ang isang Fredkin gate ay
isang controlled swap gate.
Kaya ang mga simbolong ito ay
naaayon sa ideya na ang isang control Qubit ay
ipinahiwatig ng isang solid na bilog na may linya na ikinokonekta ito
sa gate na kinokontrol nito.
Sa pangkalahatan, ang mga controlled Qubit
ay hindi kailangang nasa itaas at ang mga gate na ito ay hindi
kailangang kumikilos sa mga kalapit na Qubit, ibig sabihin na ang mga gate na ito
ay maaaring mapahabang sa kabila ng
iba pang mga Qubit na hindi nila kinakilos, at makikita natin iyon
sa mga susunod na aralin.
Isa pang bagay na madalas nating ginagawa kapag gumagamit ng quantum circuit model ay ang pagtingin sa mga arbitrary unitary na operasyon
sa anumang bilang ng Qubit
bilang mga solong gate tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Sa pamamagitan lamang ng paggguhit ng isang rektanggulo na may label na katumbas
ng anumang unitary na operasyon ito.
Sa kasong ito ito ay ilang
unitary na operasyon U.
Siyempre, hindi natin alam
kung ano ang U mula sa diagram na ito, dapat nating ipalagay na
ang U ay tinukoy sa isang paraan o na isinasaalang-alang natin ang ilang arbitrary
unitary na operasyon U, marahil. Maaari halimbawa na
gusto lang nating isipin ang U na parang isang subroutine
para sa kalinawan.
Gumagamit din tayo ng notasyong ito
na nakikita mo dito para sa isang controlled U na operasyon
kung saan ang control Qubit ay ipinahiwatig ng isang solid na bilog
tulad ng mayroon tayo noon.
Kaya iyon ay isang maikling panimula
sa quantum circuit model. At gaya ng sinabi ko kanina, makikita natin ang marami pang
halimbawa ng mga quantum circuit
habang nagpapatuloy tayo sa serye.
Sa susunod na bahagi ng aralin, titingnan natin ang
mga inner product, orthonormality at projection, na mga napakahalagang konsepto
sa quantum information at computation.
Magsisimula tayo sa mga inner product.
Alalahanin na kapag ginagamit natin ang direktang notasyon, ang isang Ket ay isang column vector
at ang isang Bra ay isang row vector,
at partikular na ang
Bra vector na katumbas ng isang ibinigay na column vector ay ang conjugate transpose
ng column vector na iyon.
Kaya para sa vector na ito dito, nakukuha natin ang katumbas na Bra vector sa pamamagitan ng pag-transpose ng vector
na parang ito ay isang matrix,
na nagkakahulugan ng paglalagay nito sa gilid nito at pagkatapos ay pagkuha ng complex conjugate ng bawat isa sa mga entry.
Ngayon, ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang Ket na may parehong bilang ng mga entry tulad nito.
Kung bubuo tayo ng bracket na ito dito, na nangangahulugang lamang na
kinukuha natin ang produkto ng Bra at ng Ket,
na parang mga matrix sila,
makukuha natin ang ekspresyong ito
na nakikita mo dito, na isang scaler, o sa
ibang salita ay isang complex number.
Ang halagang ito ay tinatawag na inner
product ng dalawang vector na ito.
Maaari mo ring isipin ang mga inner product sa mga tuntunin ng mga vector ng
anyong nakikita mo dito kung saan ang mga vector ay ipinahayag
bilang mga linear na kumbinasyon
ng mga standard basis vector.
Ang inner product ng mga vector na ito ay tinukoy sa parehong paraan bilang
dati, Bra Psi times Ket Phi na maaari nating ipahayag
bilang isang produkto tulad nito.
At kung kukwenta at pasimplehin natin, naiwan tayo sa ekspresyong ito dito para sa inner product, na kapareho ng mayroon tayo noon,
maliban sa pagkakataong ito ay
kinukuha natin ang kabuuan sa mga elemento sa ating klasikal na state set, na siyang sigma sa partikular na kasong ito.
Narito ang isang halimbawa na nilayon upang bigyan ka ng isang geometric na larawan para sa
kung paano gumagana ang mga inner product.
Dito ay gumuhit ako ng isang bilog
sa isang dalawang-dimensyonal na espasyo na katumbas ng isang Qubit, at hangga't inilalapat natin ang ating atensyon
sa mga vector na may mga real number na entry, maaari nating iguhit ang mga ito bilang mga punto sa planong ito.
Hayaan nating maging Phi
ang vector na ito dito.
Ito ay isang unit vector, na maaari nating makita sa pamamagitan ng
pagkalkula ng Euclidean norm at iyon ang kinakatawan ng bilog na ito,
lahat ng unit vector
na may mga real number na entry.
Sabihin din nating ang Psi ay
ang vector na ito dito, na muli ay isa ring unit vector.
Ito ay ang minus state sa katunayan, ngunit dito tinatawag na lang natin itong Psi.
Kung kukwentahin natin ang inner
product ng dalawang vector na ito, makukuha natin ang isa minus ang square root ng tatlo sa dalawa times root dalawa,
na nangyayaring humigit-kumulang -1/4.
Ang halaga ng inner product na ito ay katumbas ng cosine ng anggulo
sa pagitan ng dalawang vector, na maaari mong makita dito sa pigura.
Iyon ay
pangkalahatang totoo para sa mga unit vector. Kung mayroon tayong dalawang unit vector at parehong may mga real number na entry,
ang inner product sa pagitan nila ay katumbas ng cosine ng
anggulo sa pagitan nila.
Sa partikular, kung ang inner
product ay katumbas ng zero, tulad ng sa halimbawang ito, kung saan binago natin ang Psi upang maging
estado na ito dito,
ang dalawang vector ay dapat
na nasa 90 degree na anggulo sa isa't isa.
Ito ay lahat ay nagpapalawak sa
mga vector sa anumang dimensyon, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, hangga't ang
mga entry ay mga real number, hindi lamang ito para sa dalawang dimensyonal na mga vector.
Kung mayroon tayong mga complex number na entry, ang larawan ay hindi talaga
gumagana pa, ngunit gayunpaman, ang inner product ay kasing-kapaki-pakinabang
tulad ng makikita natin.
Ang inner product ay may ilang
napakahalagang katangian at maglalaan tayo ng ilang sandali upang mapansin ang ilan sa mga katangiang iyon ngayon.
Una ay isang koneksyon
sa pagitan ng inner product at ng Euclidean norm.
Kung kukuha tayo ng inner product
ng anumang vector sa mismo nito, makukuha natin ang Euclidean norm squared.
Kaya maaari nating sabihing katuwiran na ang Euclidean norm ng isang vector ay katumbas ng square
root ng inner product
ng vector na iyon sa mismo nito. Hindi ito isang pagkakataon, ito ay
isang pangunahing koneksyon, at dito maaari nating makita na kung wala tayo ng
mga complex conjugate sa kahulugan ng inner product, ang formula na ito
ay hindi na magiging totoo, at hindi natin magkakaroon ng ganitong kapaki-pakinabang na konsepto
na may pangunahing koneksyong ito
sa Euclidean norm.
Susunod, ang inner product
ay conjugate symmetric, na nangangahulugang na kung papalitan natin
ang order ng dalawang argumento, ang halagang makukuha natin para sa
inner product ay magiging conjugated.
Iyon ay ipinahayag ng
ekwasyong ito dito at medyo diretso makita kung bakit ito nangyayari para sa dalawang ekspresyong ito
para sa inner product ng dalawang vector sa dalawang posibleng pagkakasunod-sunod.
Ang inner product ay linear
sa pangalawang argumento. Sa partikular, kung tutukuyin natin ang isang vector Phi bilang linear
na kumbinasyong ito ng dalawang vector,
Phi isa at Phi dalawa, ang inner product ng
anumang vector Psi na may Phi ay ang parehong linear na kumbinasyon
ng dalawang inner product,
at ito ay sumusunod nang medyo
direkta mula sa katotohanan na ang matrix multiplication ay linear.
At mayroon din tayong ang inner
product ay conjugate linear sa unang argumento, na maaari mong makita na ipinahayag dito.
Kung ang Psi ay linear
na kumbinasyong ito ng mga vector, kung kukuha tayo ng inner
product ng Psi at Phi,
ang Bra Psi ay nagiging vector na ito na nakikita natin dito kung saan kinukuha natin ang complex
conjugate ng beta isa at beta dalawa,
at kaya ito ang resulta at iyon ang tinutukoy
ng conjugate linearity.
At ang huling katangian ng inner product na gusto kong banggitin ay
ang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na Cauchy-Schwarz inequality.
Para sa anumang dalawang vector, Psi at Phi, ang absolute value ng inner product ay hindi maaaring maging mas malaki kaysa sa
produkto ng mga Euclidean norm
ng dalawang vector. At bukod dito, ang tanging paraan na ang dalawang
panig ng inequality ay maaaring maging pantay ay kung ang dalawang
vector ay linearly dependent,
na nangangahulugang ang isa sa kanila ay katumbas ng ilang scaler times ang isa.
Ito ay sa katunayan isa sa
pinaka-malawakang ginagamit na inequality sa lahat ng matematika at
ginagamit natin ito nang paulit-ulit kapag nag-uusap tayo tungkol sa
quantum information,
kaya napakagandang malaman ito.
Susunod, pag-uusapan natin ang mga
konsepto ng orthogonality at orthonormality na
konektado sa mga inner product
at partikular na, sa
mga inner product ng mga vector na katumbas ng zero.
Upang maging tumpak, kung mayroon tayong
dalawang vector, Psi at Phi, sinasabi nating sila ay orthogonal
kung ang kanilang inner product
ay katumbas ng zero. At ang paraan na maaari nating isipin
ang tungkol sa mga orthogonal na vector nang intuitibo ay na sila ay
nasa mga tamang anggulo sa isa't isa,
o katuwiran, na sila ay
perpendikular sa isa't isa.
Minsan ay ginagamit ng mga tao ang termino orthogoal upang tumukoy sa mga bagay na
walang kinalaman sa isa't isa, tulad ng pagsasabi na ang isang isyu
ay orthogonal sa isa pa,
ngunit iyon ay malinaw na medyo impormal at hindi talaga may kahulugan
sa matematikong kahulugan, ngunit ang koneksyon ay malinaw kung iniisip mo ang mga orthogonal
na vector bilang nagtaturo
hindi sa magkasalungat na direksyon, kundi sa ganap na magkaibang direksyon tulad ng hilaga kumpara sa kanluran halimbawa.
Kung mayroon tayong isang set ng mga vector, sinasabi nating ang set ay isang orthogonal set kung ang anumang dalawang magkaibang vector
na pinili mula sa set na iyon
ay kinakailangang orthogonal sa isa't isa, na maaari nating ipahayag
tulad ng nakikita mo dito,
Ang isang orthonormal set ay
simpleng isang orthogonal set ng mga unit vector.
Ang mga vector sa mga orthogonal
na set ay hindi kailangang maging mga unit vector, at sa katunayan maaari ka ring magkaroon ng zero vector
na isang elemento ng isang orthogonal set, ngunit sa isang orthonormal set, ang bawat vector ay dapat maging isang unit vector
bilang karagdagan sa
kinakailangan na ang set ay isang orthogonal set.
Batay sa alam natin tungkol sa relasyon sa pagitan ng inner product
at ng Euclidean norm, maaari nating ipahayag ang kondisyong ito nang medyo maikli
tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
At sa wakas, ang isang orthonormal basis ay simpleng isang orthonormal
set na bumubuo ng isang basis para sa anumang vector space
na pinag-uusapan natin.
Halimbawa, kung kukuha tayo ng anumang
klasikal na state set sigma at iniisip natin ang set ng
lahat ng standard basis vector,
makikita natin na ito ay isang orthonormal set at sa katunayan ito ay isang orthonormal basis para sa espasyo ng lahat ng vector na ang mga entry ay katumbas ng
klasikal na state set sigma na ito.
Lahat ng ito ay mga unit vector at
sila ay orthogonal sa mga pares, kaya ito ay isang orthonormal set.
at dahil ito rin ay isang basis, mayroon tayong na ito ay isang orthonormal basis.
Ang mga orthonormal set ay
laging linearly independent sa pamamagitan ng paraan, kaya sa tuwing mayroon kang
isang orthonormal set, ito ay laging magiging isang orthonormal
basis para sa ilang subspace,
ngunit sa kasong ito, mayroon tayong isang basis para sa buong espasyong pinagtatrabahuhan natin.
Isa pang halimbawa ay ang set
na naglalaman ng Ket+ at Ket-.
Ang dalawang vector na ito ay orthogonal, ang kanilang inner product ay katumbas ng zero.
at parehong sila ay mga unit vector at sinasalaw nila ang
dalawang-dimensyonal na espasyo ng vector na katumbas ng isang solong Qubit, kaya bumubuo sila ng isang orthonormal
basis para sa espasyong iyon.
Isa pang halimbawa ay ang Bell basis, na isang orthonormal basis para sa espasyo ng lahat ng
apat na dimensyonal na vector na katumbas ng dalawang Qubit.
Ang set na naglalaman ng Ket 0
at Ket+ sa kabilang banda, ay hindi isang orthogonal set dahil ang inner product sa pagitan ng
mga vector na ito ay hindi zero.
Parehong sila ay mga unit vector at ito ay isang basis para sa vector space na katumbas ng isang Qubit, ngunit wala tayong orthogonality.
Narito ang isang maginhawang katotohanan tungkol sa mga orthonormal set na gagamitin natin paminsan-minsan.
Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong ilang
orthonormal set ng mga vector, partikular, ipagpalagay natin
na mayroon tayong M na vector sa set na ito, Psi isa hanggang Psi M,
kung saan ipinapalagay natin na ang mga vector na ito ay kinuha mula sa ilang N
dimensyonal na vector space, o sa ibang salita, ang bawat isa sa
mga vector ay may M na entry.
Gaya ng nabanggit ko na, ang mga orthonormal set ay laging
linearly independent, kaya hindi maaaring ang M ay mas malaki kaysa sa N,
ngunit maaaring ang M ay mas maliit kaysa sa N, at iyon ang kaso na
interesado tayo.
At ang sinasabi ng katotohanang ito ay
na kung ang M ay mas maliit kaysa sa N, laging posible
na magdagdag ng mga karagdagang vector
sa set na sinimulan natin upang makakuha ng isang
orthonormal basis para sa ating espasyo.
Upang maging tumpak, kinakailangang
mayroon talagang mga vector Psi M+1 hanggang Psi N upang ang buong koleksyon
ay bumuo ng isang orthonormal basis.
Kaya hindi mo maaaring maisapin ang iyong sarili
sa isang sulok, para magsalita, sa pamamagitan ng pagpili ng isang
orthonormal set ng mga vector na hindi maaaring palawigin upang
bumuo ng isang orthonormal basis.
Minsan ay maaari mong tingnan lang
ang set na sinimulan mo at alamin kung paano ito palawakin upang bumuo ng isang orthonormal basis, ngunit ang isang alternatibo na laging gumagana
ay ang paggamit ng isang pamamaraan na kilala bilang Gram-Schmidt
orthonormalization process upang magsagawa ng mga vector na ito.
Hindi ko ipapaliwanag ang
pamamaraang iyon sa araling ito o sa seryeng ito dahil ang mga detalye ay hindi
talaga mahalaga para sa atin, ngunit siyempre maaari mong hanapin ito kung mausisa ka.
Ito ay isang bagay na maaaring
isagawa ng isang computer kung sakaling may kaugnayan iyon, kaya
walang kasangkot na pagkamalikhain, ito ay isang mekanikal lamang na pamamaraan.
Isa sa mga dahilan kung bakit ito ay
napakamaginhawang katotohanan na mayroon ay nauugnay sa isang malapit na koneksyon na mayroon sa pagitan ng mga orthonormal
na basis at ng mga unitary matrix.
Sa partikular, para sa anumang square matrix U, ang tatlong kondisyon na nakikita mo dito ay laging katumbas,
na nangangahulugang sila ay
lahat totoo o lahat sila ay mali.
Ang unang kondisyon ay nagsasabi
na ang U ay isang unitary matrix, na nangangahulugang ang parehong U dagger times U at U times U dagger ay parehong
katumbas ng identity matrix.
Ang pangalawang kondisyon
ay nagsasabi na ang mga row ng U ay bumubuo ng isang orthonormal basis
at ang ikatlong kondisyon ay nagsasabi na ang mga column ng U
ay bumubuo ng isang orthonormal basis.
Hindi talaga mahirap
makita kung bakit totoo ang katumbasan na ito.
Para lang panatilihing simple, tingnan natin ang isang
tatlo sa tatlong matrix U tulad ng nakikita mo dito, kung saan ang mga entry ay maaaring maging anumang
complex number na gusto mo.
Dito sa kaliwang bahagi ay isinulat ko ang U conjugate transposed
para sa kaginhawahan.
Kung buo tayo ng tatlong vector
mula sa mga column ng U, na dito ay pinangalanang Psi
isa, Psi dalawa at Psi tatlo, pagkatapos ay kung kukuha tayo ng
produkto ng U dagger at U,
maaari mong suriin na ang bawat
entry ng produkto ay ibinibigay ng isang inner product ng mga vector tulad ng nakikita natin dito sa pattern na ito.
At ngayon kapag nag-iisip ka tungkol sa kondisyon na ang U ay unitary, na katumbas ng matrix na ito na katumbas ng identity matrix,
makikita mo na ito ay katumbas
ng tatlong vector na bumubuo ng isang orthonormal set.
Ang mga diagonal entry ay lahat
kailangang katumbas ng isa, kaya ang mga ito ay kinakailangang mga unit vector, at ang mga off diagonal
na entry ay kailangang maging zero,
kaya ito ay isang orthogonal set ng mga vector.
Kaya ang U na maging unitary ay katumbas ng mga column na bumubuo ng isang orthonormal set,
At iyon ay kailangang maging isang basis dahil ang bilang ng mga vector sa set, na tatlo sa kasong ito, ay naaayon sa dimensyon ng espasyo
na pinagtatrabahuhan natin. Maaari kang sumunod ng katulad na argumento para sa mga row sa halip na sa mga column upang tapusin na ang U na maging
unitary ay katumbas
sa mga row na bumubuo ng isang orthonormal basis.
Hindi ito gumagana nang eksakto nang maayos dahil kailangan nating gumawa ng pagsasaayos upang ang mga complex conjugate
ay gumana sa tamang paraan, ngunit ang ideya ay pareho.
Isang alternatibong paraan upang gawin ito, na medyo diretso, ay patunayan na ang isang matrix ay unitary kung at kung lamang ang naka-transpose nito ay unitary.
At dito ay ibig ko talagang sabihin ang transpose at hindi ang conjugate transpose.
Medyo walang-hanggan mula sa
kahulugan ng mga unitary matrix, na ang conjugate transpose
ng anumang unitary matrix ay unitary,
ngunit totoo rin na ang transpose ng anumang unitary matrix ay unitary.
Sa anumang kaso, mayroon tayong
katumbasan sa pagitan ng tatlong kondisyong ito sa anumang square matrix U, at maaari nating pagsamahin ang katumbasang ito
sa katotohanan tungkol sa
pagpapalawak ng mga orthonormal set upang bumuo ng mga orthonormal basis upang makabuo ng mga unitary matrix
na gumagawa ng mga kawili-wiling bagay
o tumutupad sa iba't ibang pangangailangan na maaaring maranasan natin.
Sa partikular, sa tuwing mayroon tayong
isang orthonormal set ng M vector, laging mayroon talagang unitary matrix U
na ang mga unang M na column ay ang mga vector mula sa orthonormal set na iyon.
Ang mga natitirang column
ay laging maaaring mapunan upang makakuha tayo ng isang unitary matrix sa pamamagitan ng pagpili sa kanila upang ang mga column ay bumuo ng
isang orthonormal basis. Ito ay magiging medyo
maginhawang katotohanan para sa atin na magkaroon sa ating pagtatapon.
At isa pang paksa para sa
seksyong ito ng aralin ay ang konsepto ng isang projection.
Isang square matrix Pi ay
sinasabing isang projection o isang projection matrix kung ang dalawang katangian na
nakalista dito ay parehong totoo.
Ito ay isang malaking titik Pi sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ito ay isang medyo tipikal na pagpili para sa isang titik na ginagamit upang tukuyin ang isang projection.
Madalas naming binibigyan ng mga tipikal na ganitong pangalan ang mga bagay tulad ng mga matrix upang maging mas madaling makilala ang mga ito at mapanatiling tuwid ang mga bagay,
ngunit maaari kang gumamit ng anumang pangalan na gusto mo. Anyway, ang unang kondisyon ay na ang Pi ay katumbas ng sarili nitong conjugate transpose.
Sa pangkalahatan, kapag mayroon tayong isang matrix na katumbas ng sarili nitong
conjugate transpose, sinasabi nating ito ay isang Hermitian matrix.
Kaya ang unang kondisyon ay maaaring ding sabihing ito ay ang Pi ay Hermitian.
Ang pangalawang kondisyon ay
na kung isasquare natin ang Pi, ibig sabihin ay pinarami natin ang Pi
sa mismo nito, makukuha natin ang Pi muli.
Kaya ang pag-square ng Pi ay walang ginagawa dito.
Ang ideya ng isang projection
nang intuitibong nagsasalita ay na ito ay katulad sa
diwa ng pagproyekto ng isang larawan sa isang screen o pagbaba ng
perpendikular sa isang linya
halimbawa. Kapag pinarami mo ang isang
vector ng isang projection, ang ginagawa mo ay sa ilang kahulugan
iniiwan ang isang bahagi nito nang mag-isa
at pinapalabas ang natitirang bahagi.
Kaya kung ilalapat mo ang isang
projection sa pangalawang pagkakataon, hindi na ito gumagawa ng anuman dahil
na-zero out mo na ang bahagi na pine-zero out ng projection.
Isang halimbawa ng isang projection
ay ang matrix na ito dito para sa anumang pagpili ng isang unit vector Psi.
Maaari nating suriin na natutugunan nito
ang mga kinakailangang kondisyon nang isa-isa.
Para sa una, kinukwenta natin
ang conjugate transpose at ito ay ang conjugate
transpose ng isang produkto.
At kaya maaari nating gamitin ang formula na ito dito para sa conjugate transpose
ng isang produkto upang tulungan tayo.
Ang makukuha mo ay ang produkto
ng mga conjugate transpose, ngunit ang order ay nababaligtad.
Iyon ay nangyayari dahil
sa bahaging transposisyon.
Kaya kung ilalapat natin ang formula na iyon, makukuha natin ang pagkakapantay-pantay na ito dito at maaari nating simplifihin upang
maibalik ang orihinal na matrix.
Pansinin sa pamamagitan ng paraan, na hindi natin ginamit ang katotohanan
na ang Psi ay isang unit vector.
Kaya sa katunayan, ang matrix na ito ay
Hermitian para sa anumang vector Psi, hindi lamang para sa mga unit vector.
At para sa pangalawa, isquare natin ang Pi at makukuha natin
ang ekspresyong ito dito at iyon ay katumbas ng
orihinal na matrix sa pagkakataong ito
dahil ang Psi ay isang unit vector, kaya ang inner product
na ito dito ay katumbas ng isa at doon pumapasok ang palagay
na ang Psi ay isang unit vector
sa laruan.
Maaari nating pangkalahatanin ang halimbawang ito at magsimula sa isang orthonormal set.
At kung buo tayo ng matrix na ito dito, kung saan isinasama natin ang mga projection na katumbas ng mga indibidwal na vector, makakakuha tayo ng isang projection.
Dito sa screen, maaari mong makita ang mga kalkulasyon na nagpapakita nito at iiwan ko ito sa iyo upang
suriin ang mga ito kung gusto mo.
At katulad ng sa unang halimbawa, ito ay ang pangalawang kondisyon kung saan ang orthonormality
ng set ay ginagamit.
Kung ano ang ginagawa ng projection na ito kung
pinarami mo ito sa isang vector, ay ang pag-project ng vector na iyon
sa subspace na sinasalaw ng set ng mga vector na ito,
na sa abstract na paraan ay
parang pagbaba ng perpendikular sa subspace na iyon, at kapag
nasa subspace ka na, ang projection ay hindi na gumagawa ng anuman.
Kaya ang mga matrix tulad nito ay
mga halimbawa ng mga projection, at ngayon sa katunayan napagod na natin
ang lahat ng mga posibilidad.
Ang bawat projection matrix ay kumukuha ng anyo na ito para sa ilang pagpili ng isang orthonormal set.
Ang zero matrix ay isang projection, kaya kailangan nating
tiyaking kasama natin ito kung gusto nating makuha ang bawat projection.
Kaya para lamang maging malinaw tungkol dito, pinapayagan natin ang
posibilidad na ang M ay katumbas ng zero at nagbibigay iyon sa atin ng isang walang laman na kabuuan,
na maaari nating bigyang-kahulugan bilang ang zero matrix.
Ngayon na mayroon tayong
konsepto ng isang projection, maaari tayong magdefine ng mas pangkalahatang
klase ng mga quantum measurement na kilala bilang projective measurement.
Hindi ito ang pinaka-pangkalahatang
konsepto ng isang pagsukat, ngunit ito ay mas pangkalahatan kaysa sa mga standard basis measurement
at magiging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang
na isama ito sa ating paglalarawan
ng quantum information.
Ang isang projective measurement ay tinukoy ng anumang set ng mga projection
na natutugunan ang kondisyon na nakikita mo dito, na ang mga projection ay
nagdaragdag sa identity matrix.
Dito ang M ay maaaring maging anumang
positibong integer na gusto mo hangga't lahat sila ay mga projection at totoo ang kondisyong ito,
ang koleksyon ay nagtatakda ng isang
projective measurement.
Ang pagsukat na inilarawan
ng ganitong koleksyon ay gumagana tulad ng sumusunod kapag
sinusukat mo ang anumang quantum state Psi.
Una ay makakakuha ka ng isang kinalabasan
sa pagitan ng isa at M, kung saan ang M ay ang bilang ng mga projection.
Para sa bawat posibleng kinalabasan, K, ang probabilidad na makuha ang kinalabasan na iyon ay ang Euclidean norm
squared ng vector na nakukuha mo
sa pamamagitan ng pagpaparami ng S ng Pi
K, ang Kth projection.
Maaari rin nating isulat ang
dami na ito tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Ang pagkakapantay-pantay na ito ay nagmumula sa relasyon sa pagitan ng Euclidean
norm at ng inner product kasama ang katotohanan
na ang Pi K ay isang projection.
Mula sa pangalawang anyo, kasama ang kondisyon na mayroon tayo sa mga projection na ito, maaari nating makita agad, sa pamamagitan ng linearity, na ang ating mga probabilidad
ay laging nagdaragdag sa isa,
na isinasaalang-alang na ang Psi
ay kailangang maging isang unit vector.
At pangalawa, ipagpalagay na
nakuha natin ang kinalabasan, K, ang estado ng sistema
ay nagko-collapse sa quantum state na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-normalize ng anumang
vector na nakuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-project.
Titingnan natin ang ilang
mga halimbawa sa ilang sandali, ngunit bago natin gawin iyon, banggitin ko na hindi talaga natin kailangan
na bilangan ang mga posibleng
kinalabasan mula isa hanggang M. Maaari tayong pumili ng anumang mga pangalan o simbolo na gusto natin para sa mga kinalabasan.
Sa partikular, kung mayroon tayong isang koleksyon ng mga projection na may label na may mga simbolo
mula sa ilang set gamma sabihin,
at natutugunan nila ang
parehong kondisyon tulad ng dati, na ang mga ito ay nagdaragdag
sa identity matrix, mayroon tayong projective measurement
na gumagana sa eksaktong
parehong paraan tulad ng dati.
Ang tanging pagkakaiba dito ay pinapayagan natin ang
mga kinalabasan ng pagsukat na maging mga elemento ng set gamma na ito bilang kabaligtaran ng mga integer mula isa hanggang M.
Para sa ating unang halimbawa ng
isang projective measurement, obserbahan natin na
ang mga standard basis measurement ay mga projective measurement.
Sa kasong ito ang set ng
mga kinalabasan ng pagsukat ay kapareho ng set ng mga klasikal na estado ng anumang sistema ang sinusukat.
At ang set ng mga projection
na naglalarawan ng pagsukat ay ang koleksyong ito dito, ipagpalagay na ang sigma ay
ang klasikal na state set
ng ating sistema. Lahat sila ay mga projection
at kung idinaragdag natin ang mga ito, makukuha natin ang identity matrix, kaya ito ay isang valid na projective measurement
Upang makita kung paano ito gumagana sa
kaunti pang detalye, ipagpalagay nating mayroon
tayong ilang arbitrary na estado na isinulat sa anyo
na nakikita mo dito.
Ang probabilidad para sa
pagsukat na magbunga ng kinalabasan A, ayon sa paglalarawan
mula ilang sandali ang nakakaraan, ay ang halagang ito dito,
na katumbas ng
absolute value squared ng katumbas na
entry ng vector Psi, na iyon ang inaasahan natin.
Nakondisyon sa kinalabasan na A, ang estado ng sistema ay nagiging ito, muli, ayon sa
paglalarawan mula ilang sandali ang nakakaraan.
Kung simplifihin natin, hindi talaga
natin makukuha ang estado na inaasahan natin, na siyang Ket A.
Sa halip makukuha natin ang Ket A
pinarami ng isang scaler, at partikular, ito ay isang scaler na may
absolute value na katumbas ng isa,
kaya ito ay isang complex number
sa unit circle.
Ito ay tinatawag na global phase at tatalakayin natin ang mga global phase sa lalong madaling panahon, ngunit sa ngayon nang maikli, ang
estado na ito ay katumbas ng Ket A.
Ang global phase na ito ay
wala talagang anumang kahalagahan at makikita natin kung bakit
kapag dumating tayo sa talakayan ng mga global phase.
Kaya (hindi malinaw) ang isyung ito ng mga global phase, na pag-uusapan natin sa isang sandali, makikita natin na ang mga standard basis measurement
ay sa katunayan mga projective measurement. Para sa isa pang halimbawa, na talagang isang pagpapalawak
ng nakaraang halimbawa,
kung magsagawa tayo ng isang standard basis
measurement sa isang sistema X at walang ginagawa sa isang sistema Y, tulad ng pinag-usapan natin
sa nakaraang aralin,
ito ay ganap na katumbas
ng pagsukat sa sistema X, Y.
Sa projective
measurement na ito dito.
Mayroon tayong mga projection na katumbas ng mga klasikal na estado ng X at nagtte-tensor tayo ng identity sa Y
na sumasalamin sa katotohanan na
hindi tayo gumagawa ng anuman sa Y.
Ang paglalarawan para sa kung paano
gumagana ang mga projective measurement sa pangkalahatan ay nagsasabi sa atin
kung ano ang nangyayari sa halimbawang ito, at iiwan ko ito sa iyo upang
suriin na ito ay sa katunayan
ganap na katumbas ng kung ano ang pinag-usapan natin sa nakaraang aralin.
Ito ay lahat ay napakaganda dahil ang paglalarawan ng projective
measurement na ito ay mas malinis sa isang paraan at nakikita natin na ito ay akma sa
mas pangkalahatang larawang ito.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa ng
isang projective measurement.
Ang isang ito ay isang pagsukat ng dalawang Qubit.
Para sa pagsukat na ito
mayroon tayong dalawang projection at samakatuwid, dalawang posibleng
kinalabasan na zero at isa.
Ang mga projection ay tinukoy
sa mga tuntunin ng mga Bell state tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Ang unang projection ay
sa espasyong sinasalaw ng tatlong symmetric Bell state at ang pangalawang projection ay
sa isang dimensyonal na espasyo
na sinasalaw ng Psi- state, na siyang anti-symmetric, o sa ibang salita ang
isang na pinarami
ng isang minus sign kung
magsasagawa tayo ng swap na operasyon sa dalawang Qubit.
Makikita natin sa ibang pagkakataon sa serye kung bakit ito ay isang kawili-wiling pagsukat.
Sa ngayon, halimbawa lang ito
na kumokonekta sa isang bagay na nakita na natin,
na siyang Bell basis.
Isang panghuling tala sa mga projective measurement ay na sa tuwing mayroon kang
isang projective measurement, lagi mong maipapatupad ang pagsukat na iyon
gamit ang mga unitary na operasyon at
mga standard basis measurement.
Para sa partikular na halimbawang ito ng
isang pagsukat, halimbawa, maaari kaming gumawa ng quantum circuit na nagpapatupad ng pagsukat
tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Iniisip natin na ang nangungunang
dalawang Qubit ay ang mga Qubit na sinusukat natin gamit ang
projective measurement na ito at ang magagawa natin ay
magpakilala ng isang bagong Qubit
na nagsisimula nang nasimulan
sa zero state. Magsasagawa tayo ng Hadamard gate
na sinusundan ng isang Fredkin gate, na sinusundan ng isa pang Hadamard gate,
at kung susukat tayo ng Qubit sa ibaba gamit ang isang standard basis measurement, ang epekto ay eksaktong kapareho ng kung sinukat natin ang nangungunang dalawang Qubit
gamit ang projective
measurement mula sa halimbawang ito.
Makukuha natin ang eksaktong parehong mga probabilidad para sa dalawang kinalabasan at ang epekto na mayroon ang pagsukat sa nangungunang dalawang Qubit
ay magiging pareho rin.
Hindi iyon malinaw sa lahat. Kailangan ng pagsusuri upang makita iyon at ang pagsususuring iyon ay hindi ipinapakita dito.
Gaya ng iminumungkahi ko na, titingnan natin nang mas malapit ang
partikular na pagsukat na ito sa isang susunod na aralin at sa ngayon
ito ay nilayong maging halimbawa lamang.
Ang mahalagang puntong dapat dalhin ay na ang isang bagay tulad nito
ay laging posible para sa anumang projective measurement, kaya hindi talaga tayo nakakakuha ng
anumang karagdagang kakayahan
sa pamamagitan ng pagpapakilala ng mga projective measurement, ngunit ito ay isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na konsepto at madalas nating pag-uusapan ang mga projective measurement
habang nagpapatuloy tayo sa serye. Ang huling bahagi ng araling ito ay tungkol sa ilang mahahalagang limitasyon
ng quantum information
at kung ano ang magagawa natin sa mga quantum circuit.
Ang unang limitasyon, na marahil ay hindi gaanong isang limitasyon kundi isang degeneracy, ay nauugnay sa isyung ng mga global phase
na nabanggit ko ilang sandali ang nakakaraan. Narito ang kahulugan ng tinutukoy natin kapag tinutukoy natin ang isang global phase.
Kung mayroon tayong dalawang quantum
state vector, Psi at Phi, tulad na ang isa sa kanila ay
katumbas ng isa pa na pinarami ng ilang complex number alpha,
sinasabi natin na ang mga estado
ay naiiba ng isang global phase o katuwiran na sila ay katumbas hanggang sa isang global phase.
Pansinin na dahil ang mga quantum state vector ay may Euclidean norm na katumbas ng isa, ang tanging paraan na ang
ekwasyong ito ay maaaring magiging totoo
ay kung ang absolute value
ng complex number na ito ay katumbas ng isa, kaya ang alpha
ay kailangang nakalagay sa unit circle.
Isipin natin na mayroon tayong
dalawang quantum state tulad nito na naiiba ng isang global phase at ipagpalagay nating susukat tayo ng estado Phi
gamit ang isang standard basis measurement.
Ang probabilidad na makuha ang anumang kinalabasan A ay ibinibigay ng ekspresyong ito dito, at kung palilitan natin ng
alpha times Psi para sa Phi,
na magagawa natin dahil
ipinapalagay nating sila ay pantay, makukuha natin ang probabilidad na ito.
At kung simplifihin natin gamit ang katotohanang nasa
complex unit circle ang alpha, makukuha natin ang probabilidad na ito.
Alalahanin na ito ay ang probabilidad na ang pagsukat ng Phi ay nagbibigay ng kinalabasan A, ngunit ngayon makikita natin na
ito ay eksaktong kapareho ng probabilidad na ang pagsukat ng
Psi ay nagbibigay ng kinalabasan A,
kaya walang
anumang pagkakaiba sa mga probabilidad ng iba't ibang kinalabasan para sa dalawang estado.
Isang katulad na argumento ang nagsasabi sa atin nang mas pangkalahatan na para sa anumang projective measurement, ang mga probabilidad ay muli na magkaparehong magkapareho.
Kaya sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat ay hindi natin
matukoy ang pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng dalawang estado na
naiiba ng isang global phase, kahit sa istatistikal na kahulugan.
Sa wakas, kung ilalapat natin ang anumang unitary
na operasyon sa estado Phi, pagkatapos ay muli sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit, ang makukuha natin ay eksaktong
kapareho ng complex number alpha
pinarami sa anumang makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng paglalapat ng parehong unitary
na operasyon sa estado, Psi.
Kaya ang dalawang estado ay magpatuloy pang
naiiba ng isang global phase.
Ang kabuuan ay na ang dalawang estado ay ganap na hindi makilala, kaya walang talagang
pagkakaiba sa pagitan nila sa lahat
sa mga tuntunin ng kung ano ang maaari
nating malaman tungkol sa kanila mula sa pagsasagawa ng mga unitary
na operasyon at mga pagsukat at para sa dahilang ito,
itinuturing natin ang dalawang
estado na ito bilang katumbas o kung gusto mo, na ito ay dalawang posibleng iba't ibang
representasyon ng vector ng
parehong quantum state.
Gaya ng sinabi ko sa
simula ng talakayan, ito ay mahalagang degeneracy
sa kung paano inilarawan ang mga quantum state ng mga quantum state vector.
Sa anumang kaso, ang ibig sabihin nito ay maaari tayong
simpleng balewalain ang mga global phase tulad ng epektibong ginawa natin kapag inilalarawan ang mga standard
basis measurement
bilang mga projective measurement. Sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang degeneracy na ito ay nangyayari lamang sa simplified na paglalarawan
ng quantum information.
Kapag inilalarawan natin ang mga quantum
state gamit ang mga density matrix, tulad ng gagawin natin sa
ikatlong yunit ng serye, magkakaroon tayo ng natatanging
representasyon ng matrix
para sa bawat quantum state. Ang isyu ng mga global phase
ay hindi na nagmumula sa pangkalahatang paglalarawan
ng quantum information.
Ito ay isa pang kaakit-akit na aspeto
ng pangkalahatang paglalarawan ng quantum information,
na patuloy kong binabanggit, ngunit anuman, ang mga global
phase ay hindi magbabagabag sa atin
dahil maaari tayong gamitin lang
ang ating kalayaan na balewalain ang mga ito.
Narito ang isang napakamabilis
na halimbawa upang tiyaking malinaw ang konsepto ng isang global phase.
Kung mayroon tayong isang minus state, at negatibong isa times isang minus state, ang dalawang estado na ito
ay naiiba ng isang global phase, at partikular mayroon tayong
alpha katumbas ng negatibong isa.
Sa kabilang banda, kung mayroon tayong isang plus state at isang minus state, hindi tayo nagkaroon ng dalawang estado
na naiiba ng isang global phase.
Ang mga ito ay mga orthogonal na vector, kaya sila ay linearly independent.
Ang pagsasabi na ang dalawang quantum state vector ay naiiba ng isang global phase
ay katumbas ng pagsasabing ang mga vector ay linearly dependent,
kaya tiyak na ang mga vector na ito
ay hindi naiiba ng isang global phase.
Totoo na ang tanging pagkakaiba ay ang plus sign na ito
nagiging minus sign na ito, ngunit iyon ang tinatawag nating
relative phase difference.
Iyon ay naiiba mula sa isang global phase dahil hindi natin
pinarparami ang buong vector ng isang complex number.
At ito ay naaayon sa katotohanan na maaari nating malaman ang pagkakaiba
sa pagitan ng mga estado na ito, partikular, kung ilalapat natin ang isang Hadamard na operasyon
at pagkatapos ay susukat, makikita natin ang zero kung ang
estado ay isang plus state at isang isa kung ang estado ay isang minus state.
Ang susunod na limitasyon ng quantum information na makikita natin sa araling ito
ay ang no-cloning theorem.
Narito ang isang pahayag ng
no-cloning theorem at ang partikular na
pahayag ng theorem na ito ay medyo kongkreto at tiyak,
na gagawing mas madaling pag-usapan. May iba pang mas pangkalahatang paraan upang ibalangkas ang no-cloning theorem,
ngunit magtutuon tayo sa isa ito sa ngayon.
Ipinapalagay natin na mayroon tayong dalawang sistema X at Y na may parehong klasikal na state set.
na binubuo ng
integer mula zero hanggang D-1 kung saan ang D ay hindi bababa sa dalawa.
Hindi talaga mahalaga kung anong mga pangalan ang mayroon ang mga klasikal na estado, ngunit sa pamamagitan ng pagpili ng mga pangalang ito ay makakatulong upang mapanatiling simple ang mga bagay.
Ang pinaka-mahalaga
dito ay na mayroon nang hindi bababa sa dalawang iba't ibang klasikal
na estado, kaya sa ibang salita, hindi tayo nag-aalala tungkol sa
trivial at hindi kawili-wiling kaso
kung saan mayroon lamang tayong isang klasikal na estado.
Ang sinasabi ng theorem ay walang unitary na operasyon U na maaari nating ilapat sa X, Y upang kung sisimulain natin
ang Y sa zero state,
mabisa tayong nakokopya o ino-clone
ang mga arbitrary na quantum state ng X.
Kung titingnan natin ang
ekspresyong ito dito nang mag-isa, ang sinasabi nito ay para sa lahat ng pagpili ng isang quantum state vector Psi ng X,
ang paglalapat ng U sa Psi tensored
sa zero state, ay nagbibigay sa atin ng Psi tensor Psi, o sa ibang salita dalawang
independent na kopya ng Psi,
kaya iyon ang ibig sabihin kung maaari tayong mag-clone ng mga quantum
state at ang sinasabi ng theorem ay hindi ito posible.
Maaari mong isipin ito
sa mga tuntunin ng mga circuit at ang sinasabi ng theorem ay
hindi ka kailanman makakagawa ng isang gate o isang circuit
na gumagana tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Kung saan isang kopya ng estado Psi ay pumapasok kasama ng isang koleksyon
ng mga nasimulaang Qubit at dalawang kopya ng Psi ang nalilikha.
Maaari mong gawin ito para sa ilang
pagpili ng estado Psi, ngunit hindi ka kailanman makakagawa ng
isang circuit na gumagana nang ganito para sa bawat quantum state Psi,
at iyon ang sinasabi ng theorem.
Medyo madali ang patunayan
ang theorem na ito, sa katunayan, ito ay mahalagang bumababa sa katotohanan na ang transformasyon na
hinahanap natin ay hindi linear,
ngunit ang mga unitary na operasyon ay
linear, kaya hindi lang ito gumagana.
Narito ang isang argumento na may kaunti pang detalye.
Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong isang unitary na operasyon U na nag-clone ng mga standard basis
state, Ket 0 at Ket isa.
Alam natin na ang mga klasikal
na estado zero at isa ay kailangang kabilang sa ating klasikal na state set dahil ang D ay hindi bababa sa dalawa.
Ngunit ang ibig sabihin nito ay sa pamamagitan ng linearity
na kung ang X ay nasa isang plus state, na maaari nating isulat tulad nito,
ang resulta ay ang linear na kumbinasyong ito ng dalawang estado dito.
Gayunpaman, hindi iyon ang tamang gawi. Ang kinakailangan sa U ay na
ang U cloned ay isang plus state,
na nangangahulugang kailangan nating
matugunan ang ekwasyong ito dito.
Ang dalawang estado na ito ay hindi
kapareho kaya hindi ito gumagana at iyon lang ang mayroon dito.
Ilang karagdagang puna
tungkol sa no-cloning theorem.
Una, ang pahayag ng
no-cloning theorem na ito ay absolute sa ilang kahulugan.
Simpleng sinasabi nito na ang isang unitary na operasyon U na gumagana nang eksakto tulad nito
ay hindi umiiral.
Kaya maaari kang magtanong kung
mayroon bang isang unitary na operasyon U na
gumagawa nito nang humigit-kumulang na may kinalabasan sa ilang paraan ng paglalarawan
ng isang pagtatantya sa pahayag. May iba't ibang
konsepto ng pagtatantya na maaaring interesado ang isa
at makikita natin ang ilang
sa kanila sa ikatlong yunit ng serye, ngunit para sa iba't ibang
konsepto ng pagtatantya na ito,
mayroong mga dami-bilang na pahayag
ng no-cloning theorem na naglalagay ng matibay na limitasyon sa kung gaano kahusay ang maaari mong humigit-kumulang na mag-clone.
Ang pangalawang puna ay na ang pagkopya o pag-clone ng mga standard basis state ay tiyak na posible.
Halimbawa, ang isang Controlled NOT gate ay kumokopya ng mga standard basis state ng isang Qubit.
Hindi ito sumasalungat
sa no-cloning theorem. Ang punto ay na ang cloning sa kahulugan ng no-cloning theorem ay nangangailangan
na ito ay gumagana hindi lamang
para sa mga standard basis state
kundi para sa lahat ng estado.
Ang isang Controlled NOT gate
ay tiyak na hindi nag-clone ng isang plus state halimbawa.
At sa wakas, sulit na ituro na mayroon ding isang no-cloning theorem para sa
mga probabilistik na estado.
Ito ay isa lang na bagay
na hindi pinag-uusapan o pinagmamalasakitan ng mga tao.
Kung ang isang tao ay random na
pumili ng isang bit, halimbawa, para sa ilang arbitrary na paraan ng
pag-assign ng mga probabilidad sa dalawang halaga at
pagkatapos ay ibinigay sa iyo ang bit na iyon,
siyempre walang paraan para sa iyo na makakuha ng dalawang independent na sample
ng random na bit na iyon.
Hindi mo lang alam kung ano
ang mga probabilidad.
Maaari mong kopyahin ang bit tulad ng isang Controlled NOT
na kumokopya ng mga standard basis state, ngunit hindi iyon kapareho ng pag-clone ng probabilistik na estado.
Wala ka lang
sapat na impormasyon upang gawin iyon. Anumang random na bit na ibinigay sa iyo ay hindi nagpapabatid sa iyo kung ano
ang mga probabilidad.
Bit lang ito.
Ang imposibilidad ng pag-clone
ng isang probabilistik na estado ay sumusunod mula sa eksaktong parehong pangangatuwiran tulad ng sa quantum na setting.
Ang cloning ay isang non-linear na proseso, habang ang mga probabilistik na operasyon, tulad ng mga unitary na operasyon, ay linear.
Anyway, hindi nakakagulat
na hindi tayo makakapag-clone ng isang probabilistik na estado at
parang hindi ito gaanong kawili-wili tulad ng katotohanan na hindi tayo makakapag-clone ng isang quantum state,
ngunit ang punto ay simpleng mapansin na ito ay hindi isang natatanging
quantum na penomenon.
Ang panghuling limitasyon
ng quantum information na tatalakayin natin sa araling ito ay na hindi posible
na ganap na makilala
ang dalawang quantum state na hindi orthogonal.
Isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito
ay na kung ang dalawang quantum state ay maaaring ganap na makilala, kailangan silang maging orthogonal.
Ang tinutukoy natin kapag tinutukoy natin
ang isang perpektong diskriminasyon ng dalawang quantum state, Psi at Phi, ay na mayroon
ilang paraan upang matukoy ang pagkakaiba ng mga ito
nang walang anumang tsansa ng pagkakamali.
Sa mga tuntunin ng quantum circuit model, maaari nating ipahayag ito tulad ng
nakikita mo dito sa screen.
Mayroon tayong ilang unitary na operasyon U, na maaaring maipatupad
bilang isang quantum circuit o maaari nating isipin ang U nang abstract
bilang isang unitary na operasyon
at sapilitang input ang U ay kumukuha ng alinman sa estado Psi o ang estado Phi
kasama ang isang grupo ng mga nasimulaang Qubit, na maaari mong isipin bilang mga workspace Qubit na kahit papaano ay tumutulong sa
prosesong ito ng diskriminasyon.
Pagkatapos na ilapat ang U, ang nangungunang Qubit ay sinusukat ayon sa isang standard basis measurement at narito ang bahagi ng perpektong
diskriminasyon.
Kung ang input state ay Psi, ang pagsukat ay kailangang
magbigay ng kinalabasan zero, 100% ng oras, at kung
ang input state ay Phi,
ang pagsukat ay kailangang
magbigay ng kinalabasan isa, muli na may 100% na tsansa.
Hindi mahalaga kung ano ang
mga estado ng iba pang mga Qubit na ito pagkatapos na ilapat ang U.
Ang tanging mahalaga ay ang isang bit na ito na nakukuha natin mula sa pagsukat dahil iyon ang bit na nagsasabi sa atin kung alin sa dalawang estado ang sinimulan natin.
Para sa ilang pagpili ng mga estado, Psi at Phi, magiging posible na magsagawa ng perpektong diskriminasyon tulad
nito at para sa iba ay hindi.
At ang mapapansin natin ay na
kung posible itong gawin, ang Psi at Phi ay kailangang maging mga orthogonal na estado
at ang ibig sabihin nito ay kung ang Phi at
Psi ay hindi orthogonal, hindi mo sila maaaring ganap na makilala.
Kaya tingnan natin kung bakit ang perpektong diskriminasyon ay nagpapahiwatig ng orthogonality.
Magsisimula tayo sa pagsulat ng dalawang ekwasyon na nagpapahayag kung ano
ang ipinahahayag ng dalawang diagram na ito.
Kung nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa quantum state, makukuha natin pagkatapos ng paglalapat ng U sa isang
grupo ng mga nasimulaang Qubit kasama ang estado Psi,
makikita natin na kailangan nitong
magkaroon ng anyo na ito dito, kung saan ang Pi zero ay ilang quantum state vector na kumakatawan sa estado
ng lahat ng Qubit na ito
maliban sa nangungunang isa. Wala tayong impormasyon
tungkol sa quantum state na ito, Pi zero, maaari itong maging anuman,
ngunit alam natin na ang buong
estado ay kailangang magmukha tulad nito dahil iyon lang
ang paraan na ang pagsukat ay garantisadong nagbibigay ng
kinalabasan zero, 100% ng oras.
At mayroon tayong katulad na
ekwasyon para sa pangalawa.
Sa pagkakataong ito ang nangungunang Qubit
ay kailangang nasa estado isa at katulad ng Pi zero, ang
estado Pi isa ay maaaring maging anuman.
At bukod sa walang
impormasyon tungkol sa Pi isa, hindi rin natin alam ang anuman
tungkol sa relasyon sa pagitan ng Pi zero at Pi isa.
Sa lahat ng alam natin, ito ay dalawang
arbitrary na quantum state.
Ang susunod na magagawa natin ay
ang pag-multiply ng magkabilang panig ng mga ekwasyong ito sa
magkabilang panig ng U dagger, ibig sabihin ang conjugate transpose ng U.
At kung gagawin natin iyon, makukuha natin ang dalawang ekwasyon
na nakikita mo dito.
Ginagamit natin ang katotohanan na ang U dagger times U ay ang identity matrix.
Kaya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit hindi natin nakikita ang U o U dagger sa kaliwang bahagi ng alinmang ekwasyon.
At ngayon ay maaari nating isaalang-alang ang inner product sa pagitan ng Psi at Phi.
Ito ay kapareho ng inner
product ng Psi at Phi na pinarami sa inner
product ng estado L zero sa mismo nito
dahil ang inner product ng
anumang estado sa mismo nito ay isa at kasama rito ang estado L zero.
At ngayon kung titingnan natin ang ating dalawang ekwasyon, makikita natin na ang ekspresyong ito dito ay katumbas ng inner product ng mga vector
na kinakatawan ng dalawang ekwasyon. At partikular ito ay ang inner product sa pagitan ng kaliwang
bahagi ng mga ekwasyong ito.
Kaya maaari naming pantay na
ipahayag ang inner product na ito bilang ang inner product ng mga vector na kinakatawan ng kanang
bahagi ng mga ekwasyong ito,
dahil ang kaliwang bahagi ay
katumbas ng kanang bahagi para sa parehong ekwasyon.
Kaya nakukuha natin ang ekspresyong ito dito, na siyang inner product
ng dalawang kanang bahagi ng mga ekwasyon o katuwiran,
ito ay ang conjugate transpose ng una na pinarami sa pangalawa.
Ang U times U dagger ay katumbas
ng identity matrix, dahil ang U ay unitary at kaya ito ay nawawala.
At maaari tayong mag-simplify nang kaunti upang makuha ang produkto ng
mga inner product na ito.
Ngayon alalahanin na wala tayong alam tungkol sa relasyon
sa pagitan ng Pi zero at Pi isa, kaya hindi natin alam kung ano
ang kanilang inner product.
Iyon ay misteryo sa atin. Ngunit anuman ito, pinarparami natin ito sa inner product ng Ket 0 at Ket isa, na siyang zero.
Kaya ang panghuling resulta ay na
nakukuha natin ang halagang zero, ngunit iyon ang gusto nating ipakita, ang inner product sa pagitan ng
Psi at Phi ay katumbas ng zero.
Kaya ang dalawang estado ay orthogonal.
Kaya huwag nang subukan pang
ganap na makilala ang dalawang non-orthogonal na quantum
state, hindi mo talaga magagawa.
Mayroon ding kabaligtaran sa
pahayag na katatapos nating patunayan, na ang mga orthogonal na quantum state ay laging maaaring ganap na makilala,
at hindi ito mahirap makita
kung gagamitin natin ang isang katotohanang nabanggit ko kanina sa aralin.
Sa partikular kung ang Psi at
Phi ay mga orthogonal na estado, ang isang bagay na maaari nating gawin ay pumili ng anumang unitary matrix U
na ang mga unang dalawang column
ay ang dalawang estado.
Alam natin na laging
posible itong gawin at hindi mahalaga
para sa layunin ng gawaing ito kung paano eksakto pinili ang unitary matrix na ito.
Ang tanging mahalaga ay ito ang mga unang dalawang column.
Hindi tayo nangangailangan ng anumang karagdagang Qubit. Kung ilalapat lang natin ang U sa
dalawang posibleng estado, makukuha natin ang mga
dalawang posibleng kinalabasan na ito.
At kung susukat tayo sa pinaka-nangungunang Qubit, na alalahanin ay ang pinaka-kanan Qubit, makukuha natin ang zero o isa
depende sa kung aling estado ang sinimulan natin.
Katuwiran, maaari nating isaalang-alang
ang isang projective measurement na may mga kinalabasan zero hanggang isa
na tinukoy tulad ng nakikita mo dito.
Sa kasong ito, ang pagsukat
ay talagang umaasa lamang sa Psi.
Ang pagsukat na ito ay ganap na
nagpapakilala ng Psi mula sa anumang estado na orthogonal sa Psi.
Kung susukat tayo ng Psi ayon sa projective measurement na ito, makukuha natin ang kinalabasan
zero na may probabilidad na isa tulad ng inilalahad ng mga ekwasyong ito.
At para sa anumang estado Phi
na orthogonal sa Psi, makukuha natin ang kinalabasan
isa na may probabilidad na isa.
Hindi ko dadaanan ang
mga detalye ng mga kalkulasyong ito, ngunit kung interesado ka, hinihikayat kita na dumaan
sa mga detalye nang mag-isa.
At iyon ang katapusan ng aralin tatlo. Maraming materyal ang tinalakay natin sa araling ito, kasama ang mga quantum circuit,
mga inner product at orthonormality, mga projection at projective measurement, ang katotohanang ang mga global phase ay hindi mahalaga,
ang no-cloning theorem, at ang katotohanang ang mga non-orthogonal na estado ay hindi maaaring ganap na makilala habang ang mga orthogonal na estado ay maaari.
Umaasa akong sasama ka sa akin para sa
ikaapat na aralin sa lalong madaling panahon, na siyang huling aralin sa
unang yunit ng serye.
Sa ikaapat na aralin, pag-uusapan natin ang tatlong
napakahalagang halimbawa, teleportation, superdense coding,
at ang CHSH inequality o CHSH game tulad ng minsan itong inilalarawan.
Paalam hanggang sa muli,